the House of Representatives will vote
later today on the final republican tax
reform bill the senate may vote on it
tonight
vice president mike pence called off a
trip to the Middle East just in case he
has to break a tie in the Senate Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where
Republicans are confident that they have
the votes Nancy good morning
good morning in fact CBS News reached
out to all 13 House Republicans who
voted no on the original version back in
November and 11 of them tell us that
they are planning to vote no again
because they think that this bill is
unfair to people in high-tax states but
House Republicans can afford to lose up
to 22 of their own members plus all the
Democrats so GOP leaders in the house
think they are still in good shape to
pass it today the bill would then come
over to the Senate where a couple of the
final holdouts announced their support
yesterday so even with Senator John
McCain recuperating in Arizona GOP
leaders believed that they have the
votes in the Senate to send this to the
President's desk by tomorrow now as for
the content of the bill itself a new
independent analysis finds that 80% of
Americans would get a tax cut next year
while about five percent would see their
taxes go up but because all of the
individual rates are set to expire in
2025 53 percent would see a tax increase
by 2027
now as momentous as this event is for
Republicans they want to wrap it up
quickly because they have to pass a bill
by the end of the week to fund the
government otherwise they'll be risking
Anthony a government shutdown Nancy
Cordes thanks Nancy